here the nominees for achievement and  sound editing drive LAN bender and  Victor ray Ennis The Girl with the  Dragon Tattoo Ren Kleiss  Hugo Philip Stockton and Eugene Garrity  Transformers Dark of the Moon  Ethan van Duren and Eric Haydock  warhorse  Richard hems and Gary rides Hugo  Philip Stockton and  you go no Hugo I'd like to thank the  members of the Academy my crew back in  New York City you know who you are  Thelma who's indefatigable worth a cthe  is an inspiration to all of us and Marty  thank you so much for yet another  opportunity to work on an other great  film thank you so much um I just want to  thank everybody who's here tonight and  everybody who isn't and everybody who's  ever been born or maybe born or be born  again or reborn if I forgotten anybody  then you probably know who you are I  specifically want to thank Graham King  and Tim Eddington my wife Gayle my  daughter Julia Thelma Marty I love you  guys thank